il ya cet appel à la violence donc
décidé de temporiser de rester calmes
d'essayer de voir ce qu'on peut faire en
étant plutôt logique il faut agir
intelligemment
donc on essaye de se réunir on parle
beaucoup avec avec tout le monde pour
voir ce qu'on peut faire après c'est
vrai que on va essayer de pacifistes
pour le moment et après on verra si ça
marche ou ça marche pas et dans le cas
où on n'est pas écoutés on n'est pas
respectée comme ça a pu l'être pendant
un moment mais peut-être que ça passera
des choses plus plus compliqué et un peu
plus violente je dirais il était corse
est un patriote à bombay ce qu'il a fait
c'est sûr on sait pas c'est lui ou pas
donc voila mais bon beaucoup de
tristesse parce que bon d'état mal agi
je pense il serait pas là s'il avait
relâché en tout cas c'est sûr mais bon
beaucoup de tristesse dans notre coeur
et du peuple corse avec lui de tout
coeur émotion tristesse toujours un peu
de colère parce que cela on en est
arrivé là c'est que une erreur a été
fait en amont et un petit peu
d'inquiétude quand
à ce que
est ce que seront les conséquences
on ne sait pas trop comment la jeunesse
d'une part va réagir ce matin il était
très déterminé devant les établissements
mais je crois que c'est on est quand
même dans le temps de l'émotion et dans
le temps du recueillement et je crois
que ça tout le monde doit le respecter
aujourd'hui il ya eu trop dégradation
trop de débordements qui pour moi
n'était pas nécessaire on peut
manifester les choses manifester son
mécontentement tout en respectant et en
le faisant dans le calme